قضيه وثائق الرئيس الامريكي جرو بايدن
ربما تكون اسوا من حاله سلفيه ترامب وفقا
لوصف صحيفه تلغراف التي ترى ان وثائق
بايدن عثر عليها بينما هو في منصبه كرئيس
بينما ترامب عثر عليها بعد مغادرته المنصب
وترى الصحيفه ان الوضع خطير للغايه
بالنسبه لكلى الرجلين حيث يمكن ان يكون كل
منهما قد ارتكب جرائم بموجب قانون السجلات
الرئاسيه وقانون التجسس اذا كان قد تصرف
باهمال جسيم وفقا للثلاجراف
تشابه عابر تحمله وتحقيقات الجاريه بشان
الوثائق السريه المكتشفه بحوزه بايدين
وتلك التي لا تزال جاريه بحق السلفه وفق
صحيفه بوليتكو التي تخالف التلغراف في
قراءه هذه القضيه فصحيفه الامريكيه شبهت
الموقف اكثر بما حدث مع وزيره الخارجيه
السابقه هيلاري كلينتون احتفاظ غير مقصود
بمواد سريه ببريدها الالكتروني الخاص
واضافت الصحيفه ان ترامب يخضع للتحقيق
بسبب الاحتفاظ المتعمد بسجلات سريه وتجاهل
طلبات اعادتها لوزاره العدل رغم الطلبات
المتكرره من مسؤولين فترهين فاعاقه سير
العداله قد تكون تهمه بحد ذاتها حتى ولو
قرر مسؤوله وزاره العدل العامه عدم توجيه
ابتهامات تتعلق بالسجلات السريات في
المقابل طبعا محامو بايد سلم الوثائق
مباشره رغم عدم وجود خطابات لتسليمها او
مذكرات استدعاء او اوامر تفتيش ورغم ان
تحقيق بايدن لا يزال في مرحله مبكره رجحت
بوليتكو ان لا ينطبق اي من القوانين التي
يخضع ترامب لتحقيق بسببها وبسبب انتهاكها
على سلوك بيضه موضحه او مضيحه ان الاهمال
الجسيم قد يكون التهمه اي مخالفه القانون
الذي يعاقب على فقدان او حذف معلومات
الدفاع الوطني وهو ما بنى عليه مدير مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدراليه السابق تحقيقه بشان
البريد الالكتروني الخاص بهلال عليك
الانترنت
[موسيقى]